mysteriöse dinge spielen sich gerade in
der antarktis ab ein instrument das
eigentlich ultra auch energetische
neutrinos aufspüren soll
hat etwas sehr seltsames entdeckt
teilchen ströme die auch auf ultra
energetische teilchen hinweisen aber aus
der erde kommen
neutrinos reagieren zwar nicht mit
materie wenn sie durch die erde fliegen
diese teilchen waren aber so hoch
energetisch dass sie als neutrinos land
doch von der erde materie hätten
aufgehalten werden müssen was sind das
also für teilchen was ist da passiert am
südpol fixum science fiction bei uns
gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich
willkommen die antarktis ist ein
unglaubliches messinstrument ein
riesiger detektor mit einem volumen von
1,5 millionen kubikkilometer und im eis
der antarktis diesem sektor passieren
seltsame dinge zum beispiel entsteht
dort die sharing yankov strahlung das
ist einleuchtend dass durch die
kollision von neutrinos mit dem
wassermolekül des eises entsteht das
icecube observateur über das wir ja
schon berichtet haben untersucht dieses
leuchten und kann dadurch die geister
teilchen die neutrinos erforschen 5160
sensoren wurden dafür tief in den
antarktischen untergrund versenkt und
zwar bis zu 2,5 kilometer tief zusammen
bilden sie ein riesiges
dreidimensionales detektor fällt so
wurde dort erst im september 2017 der
ursprung der neutrinos gefunden damals
entdeckte der nasa gammastrahlen
satellit fermi eine riesige
gammastrahlen quelle in der galaxie txs
05 06 06 damals wurde der satellit
aufgrund der messungen des ice cubes auf
diese galaxie ausgerichtet in zentrum
ist ein glas ein aktives super
massereiches schwarzes loch das eine
extrem heiße akkretionsscheibe um sich
kreisen lässt und nach oben und unten
jets ausspuckt einer trifft uns und wir
können die strahlung messen zum einen
die gammastrahlung und zum anderen
einige wenige neutrinos und ein solches
wurde vorher im ice cube gefunden und es
gibt ein zweites experiment dort im eis
wahrscheinlich der einzige flugkörper
der nasa ihr auf der erde
ein instrument das an einem heliumballon
in 35 kilometern höhe über dem südpol
schwedes zeichnet radiowellen auf die
auch durch neutrinos ausgelöst werden
und zwar sind es ganz besondere
neutrinos nämlich ultra hoch
energetische die mit dem eis reagieren
und einen der tcherniakov strahlung
ähnlichen effekt auslösen da sie hoch
energetisch sind reagieren sie mit
materie also mit dem eis und lösen ware
teilchen schauer aus kaskaden aus
materie und antimaterie elektronen und
positronen doch da sie als hoch
energetische - mit materie reagieren
können sie nicht durch die erde geflogen
sein wie diejenigen die im ice cube
delektiert werden sie hätten dort
bereits mit der materie der erde hinter
agiert werden also aufgehalten worden
doch genau solche teilchen sind jetzt
drei mal von anita gemessen worden
sie waren hoch energetisch und sind aus
der erde gekommen also lösten ein
partikel schauer aus und es können laut
einem forschungsteam der penn state
university eben keine neutrinos gewesen
sein
sie können ja nicht aus der erde kommen
wenn sie hoch energetisch sind was ist
das also das forschungsteam um den
physiker der ipi fox geht davon aus dass
es sich um es aus handeln muss ein
elementarteilchen typ der bisher nur
hypothetisch also vorhergesagt
existierte niemand hatte ihn bisher
gefunden und das wäre eine absolute
sensation
damit wäre eine revolutionäre
erweiterung des standardmodells der
teilchenphysik eingeleitet die
supersymmetrie sie sagt voraus dass sich
personen und fermionen ineinander
umwandeln können und dass es toll wäre
genauso ein teilchen der super partner
des deb-teams einem schwester teilchen
des elektrons damit würde wirklich eine
neue ära der physik beginn fox meint
sogar dass es möglich wäre dass es am
large hadron collider am cern in genf
dem lhc zu untersuchen und sein team
meint auch in den daten des ice cubes
ungewöhnliche schauer gefunden zu haben
alles noch ein wenig unsicher
tatsächlich wird das ergebnis des
forschungsteams weltweit intensiv
diskutiert aber noch ist der aufsatz
nicht peer reviewed worden und einige
kollegen und kolleginnen meinen auch
dass es andere
erklärungen geben könne wahrscheinlicher
seien zb unverstandene reaktion des
antarktischen eises mit den neutrinos
oder oder oder ich bin jedenfalls extrem
gespannt die ersten ungewöhnlichen
teilchen schauer gab es 2006 und 2016
aber jetzt ist gerade wieder einer
festgestellt worden
und der wird gerade untersucht wow so
dass jetzt ein dickes brett ein echt
schwieriges thema wenn er findet dass es
spannend war dann abonniert doch nix zum
unerwähnt sogar mitglied mit einem
kleinen beitrag tut der gutes wir
schalten nämlich dann immer mehr werbung
vor den videos ab und ihr bekommt dafür
extra videos live streams und noch ein
paar andere privilegien einfach unter
dem video draufklicken oder auf den link
in der video beschreibung und hier geht
es weiter mit rätsel um geister teilchen
erde als gigantischer neutrino killer
dafür eben hier klicken früher bekommt
in die videos übrigens über whatsapp von
mir geschickt dafür hier klicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt